High School Musical first aired on the
Disney Channel in 2006 only to become
one of the most loved movies by Disney
fans everywhere it quickly grew into one
of the most-watched Disney Channel
Original Movies and after the last movie
aired fans would not stop demanding for
the production of a high school musical
for the good news is that Disney has
confirmed that we will definitely be
getting a reboot of the original musical
and after all these years it'll be in
the form of a high school musical the
musical series not only did fans
everywhere get exactly what they were
asking for but they now get to enjoy the
show multiple times through episodes to
come well this is some pretty awesome
news it leaves us wondering if our
favorite Wildcats are gonna be making
you back to the halls of East High one
of the stars has already tweeted that
heat is totally down for a remake
however you're gonna have to keep on
watching to find out who I know you High
School Musical fans I've been waiting
forever for some details so let's get
started oh honey if that's what you call
an invitation you'll be dancing with
yourself unlike the original B new High
School Musical movie is going to be in
the form of a television series the
series will premiere on Disney's very
own version of Netflix this new and
highly anticipated branch of Disney
media is set to be available to its
users sometime soon in 2019 Disney fans
already know that this is going to be
one of the most epic years yet for all
things Disney the TV series is actually
going to be called High School Musical
the musical but we kind of already know
that it's going to be a musical so that
makes me wonder what exactly the
creators were thinking with that title
now it's all going to make sense once I
tell you what the plot of the movie is
going to look like in the original
trilogy we get to see our favorite
lovebirds Troy and Gabriella go through
the ups and downs of high school love
some critics has even compared their
story to the modern-day version of Romeo
and Juliet
Troy was the captain of a sized
basketball team and Gabriella only a new
transfer student with a knack for
science and mathematics together the
audition for their high school musical
and landing both leads despite all the
peer pressure around them the two go on
to inspire the entire student body to
not stick to the status quo and instead
just learn to be themselves as for the
plot according to Seventeen magazine it
is going to be revolving around singing
high schoolers seriously though their
name is pretty clever since we'll be
seeing a new batch of East High Wildcats
taking on their theater winter
production
like the original though the series is
going to feature some major drama on and
off the stage as of what we know right
now the series is going to be in ten
different episodes in a docu-series
style now this means that we will
probably see in the lives of these
Wildcats unfold through one of the
characters is perspective
or maybe even a film student's camera
lens it looks like one of the lead roles
for the upcoming series has already been
cast in the month of October 2018 Disney
announced that it had found its new high
school musical start and it is none
other than Joshua that's it
FAFSA will be playing the role of
character Riki Riki is the male star of
the series and is described as a cynical
sweetheart to the lead female role
meanie just like our original heartthrob
joy Bolton Ricky gets broken up with and
spends most of his time trying to win
back his girlfriend auditioning for his
school's production of High School
Musical and hoping that him and Nene
will both get cast his leads according
to Gary Marsh who is the president and
chief creative officer Disney Channel
worldwide Joshua's interpretation of
character Ricky was winning funny and
vulnerable at the same time he even
mentioned that fans everywhere are going
to love watching him put his stamp on
the next high school musical series
franchise now I can totally believe that
because Bassett himself did mention that
he was a big fan of the movies growing
up we'll call it senior year genius well
I can't tell you for sure if Zac Efron
not 31 years old or Vanessa Hudgens now
30 will make a comeback as teenagers in
love there's still a possibility that we
might see them guest star as their
characters back on the show what I can
tell you for sure is that we have five
brand new characters aside from Ricky
and Mimi who will be showing their faces
in the upcoming series be sure to let me
know who you think these new characters
will be replacing since I have
definitely found some similarities
between the old and new set of
characters our first of the five is a
character that Ricky is not too happy
about EJ is a wildcat who soon becomes
Nene's new love interest wants her and
Ricky breakup he is a very ambitious
student who is used to getting what he
wants and not letting anybody get in his
way according to Disney EJ was voted
most likely to report a student for
cheating on a test next character up is
ashlynn an outspoken new student who
works very hard to find her place among
her peers she is EJ's cousin and even an
aspiring songwriter she was voted by
as most likely to read your palm telling
me that she is very into astronomy and
horoscopes just like Troy Ricci has a
best friend of his own and his name is
big red instead of being under the
spotlight and on stage big red likes to
help the musical by joining the
backstage crew here's a plot twist for
you guys he is only doing this to get
closer to Nene who we already said was
Ricky's girlfriend and asked for Big
Red's your book description he was voted
most likely to believe in aliens bruh
for our third new character he's got
Gina the self-proclaimed princess she
gets cast as the understudy of the
musical which does not sit well with her
throughout the storyline she is able to
get some Instagram videos of herself to
go viral making me pretty nervous about
her role as lead Gina was voted by her
class as most likely to push you down a
flight of stairs
yikes and finally for the last character
we can expect to see as of now is Vikram
Vikram is the musical score iographer he
is best friends with the drama teacher
and a Starbucks
addict
but I know where it ends center stage as
of today we haven't gotten much news of
the original cast trying to join the
television series except for one of
course this TV dad made it Instagram
official and even tagged some official
Disney pages in his post say that he
would be totally down for High School
Musical reboot let's give a little
shout-out to Coach bone himself for
sharing her enthusiasm the best part of
the story is that he even suggested the
spin-off feature himself and misses
darvis with a dance-off between an East
High Wildcats and the West High Knights
for those of you that are curious the
reason he is suggesting this is because
there was actually a dance-off
originally set to be between him and
mist Arvest that got edited out of the
original movie he said it resembled the
anything you can do I can do better kind
of songs from Annie I don't know what
the Disney creators were thinking
because that actually would have been
pretty awesome to see and we have
reached the end of our video guys as
always thank you for watching and I hope
you enjoyed our video if you did be sure
to give it a big thumbs up and spread
the things love in the community section
and comments section below
it's your own sewer and I'll see you in
our next video
[Music]
[Music]